Caldwell Banker premier Realty the
sponsor of this segment is celebrating
25 years in the valley so Bob and Molly
Hamrick know a lot about the market and
have some great ideas when it comes to
selling your home we are joined by Bob
Hamrick thanks so much for being here
Kendall how are you nice to be here it
is great to have you with us the market
right now is neither a buyer or a
seller's market is that correct it's
pretty balanced we had inventory that
grew in the shift around the April May
of last year inventory grew to about 8
700 homes we're down to about 4 500
homes now sales have started to pick up
so it is pretty balanced in any case
it's a little more competitive if you're
selling the days of just putting up a
sign and getting five offers right off
the bat probably absolutely it's not the
same yeah so uh it used to be that the
condition of the home didn't matter as
much and it truly does now it's almost
as important as price so causing the
home to be in the absolute best
condition possible is a very much
importance which means money me out of
pocket and sometimes people selling
their homes don't have that oh contraire
so correct that is true and so we're
excited to introduce a program called
real vitalized and real vitalize allows
a homeowner to fix up their home to
prepare it to compete with new homes
from a modeling model perspective so
that it sells for the highest price
possible and they're not responsible for
advancing those dollars so we advance
those dollars they pay it back at close
right they pay it on the back side of it
but they still end up making more money
than they might have otherwise the goal
is to cause the home to be very very
competitive in the marketplace and
condition is huge today so to have a
home that is somewhat remodeled new
carpeting new paint staged in a way that
causes it to really look at its best it
can cause the home to sell for the
absolute maximum dollar yeah anybody who
sold a home knows what a headache it is
to try to keep your home looking like
it's in model condition absolutely but
those little things can make a
difference they make a huge difference
and sometimes it's it's disappointing or
challenging to be able to get it in that
condition there are some by homeowners
that choose to sell to what's called an
eye buyer and the eye buyer buys the
home in its existing condition but they
put money into the home and then they
sell it for a higher price we think that
the homeowner deserves that money and so
we prepare the home and fix it up for
them so they get the most amount of
money for those who are thinking about
buying and have been sitting on the
sidelines watching prices go down for a
little bit is it time to jump in that's
a great question and everybody's trying
to find the bottom so everything that we
see is that it is at the bottom we had a
lowest sales price of 425 000 in
December of last year it has been 425
000 all the way through January and
February and prior to that it was
dropping about one to two percent every
month so I think we found the bottom we
may have plateaued absolutely Bob thanks
so much for being here really appreciate
it we want to thank Coldwell Banker
premier Realty for sponsoring this
segment you can get give them a call at
that number on your screen
725-234-2277 or visit their website at
realvitalizelv.com
[Music]